[Musik]
bvb-star mats hummels und seine ehefrau
cathy haben dass ihr sohn ende mit einem
urlaub am tegernsee gefeiert das paar
versorgt die fans regelmäßig mit
einblicken neben baden und lesen stehen
auch sportliche aktivitäten wie stand up
paddling und mountainbiken auf dem plan
gerade bei letzterem hat kathi eine
lektion gelernt
nächstes mal besser nicht mit langen
flattr hosen und flipflops losfahren
früher haben sie noch in einem team
gespielt jetzt sind mats hummels und
robert lewandowski gegner aber auch der
bayern-kicker genießt aktuell seine
freie zeit mit seiner kleinen familie
doch trotz meer und sonne wird nicht
aufs training verzichtet gemeinsam mit
ehefrau anna lewandowski ebenfalls profi
sportlerin ist zieht das paar sein
fitnessprogramm weiter durch aber
schreibt bei instagram das training sei
für sie ein fixpunkt jeder reise und sie
so hehr entspanne wenn die kleinen dann
endlich mal schlafen und nationalspieler
emre chan der postet fotos von sich auf
mykonos die griechische luxusinsel
scheint ein beliebtes ziel bei den
fußballern zu sein
[Musik]
auf dfb torwart kevin trapp verbringt
dort seinen urlaub und dreißigsten
geburtstag mit freundin isabell dollar
das supermodel zeit in ihrer instagram
story verliebte einblicke und gratuliert
ihrem schatz zum ehrentag
außerdem zeigt sie in was für einer
traumhaften kulisse die beiden ihren
urlaub verbringen
[Musik]
weltfußballer cristiano ronaldo zeigt
uns dass es manchmal auch einfach am
schönsten ist zu hause mit den kindern
zu sein und wenn man dann noch einen
pinken flamingo hat wird man glatt mit
über neun millionen likes belohnt nicht
weniger schlecht hat das national
stürmer timo werner getroffen
deutschlands erfolgreichster stürmer
teilte dieses foto von sich bei dem man
nur neidisch werden kann
leider kann man bloß raten wo es werner
hin verschlagen hat aber es sieht in
jedem fall paradiesisch aus doch selbst
der pool und die sonne können ihn nicht
davon abhalten sich schon auf die
nächste saison beim sc stellt sie
vorzubereiten
[Musik]